This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难成长的教训》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）。这个节目探讨黑人群体的生活经历，进行坦诚的对话，而这些对话在其他任何地方其实都不安全，但你是在跟一位经验丰富的持证专业人士交流。多少男人带着一身铠甲生活。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有能力就非得这么做。收听“艰难成长的教训”
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
可在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台收听。2%。这是当电梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养精神坚韧度、体能和抗压能力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终将成为一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
生活更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即“TWO%”，可在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个声名狼藉的诈骗犯交往过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的好姐妹们。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
收听《相信好姐妹，相信我，宝贝》（The Girlfriends. Trust me, babe），可在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台收听。在《回看当年》（Look Back at It）播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重大时刻。对标1984年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过那段时光的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。1984年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。收听《回看当年》，可在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台收听。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个带大家探讨二十岁时面临的重大生活改变与转型，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world, you know the deal. It's great to have you here. Thank you for tuning in. Today, we're talking about the myth of the five-year plan. I feel like all of us have some idea of what this means, you know, this sense that we need to have some concrete vision for the next five years of our lives. We need to know what we're doing, what we're working towards, have some kind of goal. And it's my belief that, you know, This idea of having a five-year plan or even a 10-year plan is a complete myth. And today, I want to explain why.
大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到这个播客。新听友、老听友，无论你身在世界何处，你们都懂的。很高兴你能来到这里。谢谢你的收听。今天，我们要聊聊“五年计划”的迷思。我觉得我们所有人对这意味着什么都有点概念，你知道的，就是那种我们需要对未来五年的生活有一个具体愿景的感觉。我们需要知道自己在做什么、在为什么努力，还要有某种目标。而我的看法是，你知道的，这种制定五年计划甚至是十年计划的想法完全是一个迷思。今天，我要解释一下这是为什么。
Even if you don't consciously realize it, from a very young age, you have been sold a very narrow idea of what your life should look like. And part of that narrative is that you should have some sense of your life plan and where you see yourself in five to 10 years as early as your 20s. For some people, I think this checks out and they feel a sense of comfort in the stability of having a blueprint for their next steps and the next season of life. But I am of the mindset that our 20s are not for planning. They are for mistakes and they are for discovery and impulsive decisions and freedom. And the idea of a five-year plan really restricts that outlook for a number of reasons.
即使你没有意识到，从很小的时候起，社会就已经向你灌输了一种非常狭隘的人生蓝图。这种叙事的一部分就是，早在二十岁的时候，你就应该对自己的生活规划以及未来五 to 十年自己会在哪里有个大致概念。对某些人来说，我觉得这挺管用的，能从拥有一份下一步和人生下一阶段的蓝图的稳定性中获得一种安全感。但我个人的心态是，我们的二十岁不是用来做计划的。二十岁是用来犯错的，是用来探索、做冲动决定和享受自由的。而五年计划这种想法，由于种种原因，实际上限制了那种广阔的视野。
I think firstly, it sells us this lie that we can plan. for the future, which we can't. Life is full of uncertainty and change, especially during this decade. And although this can feel really big and scary, it also means that some of the most life-changing and best moments of your life are ahead. And they are going to change what you want and what your definition of success and happiness really is. You know, you may feel like you are on one path now, but let me just say, what you want. What you want. wanted at 18 when you perhaps made that decision, when you decided what to study at uni, when you decided what your career would be, that is very unlikely to be the same thing that
我觉得首先，它向我们兜售了一个谎言，那就是我们可以为未来做计划，但其实我们做不到。生活充满了不确定性和变化，尤其是在这个十年里。尽管这可能会让人觉得压力山大、心生畏惧，但这也意味着你人生中最能改变命运、最美好的时刻还在前方。它们将改变你的渴望，改变你对成功和幸福的真正定义。你知道的，你现在可能觉得自己正走在某条路上，但请让我直言，你所渴望的——你所渴望的——你在18岁时也许做那个决定时、当你决定在大学里学什么专业时、当你决定你的职业生涯应该是什么样时，那些渴望，极不可能是你
you're going to want at 25. There are so many things we can never foresee or plan for. So you really need to allow yourself room to be flexible. I think secondly, boxing ourselves in at such a young age can lead us to make very emotional, unrealistic goals that just ultimately leave us feeling like failures or on a path that we actually don't really desire. You know, this creates a lot of long-term dissatisfaction and discontent because a lot of our life plans are based on shoulds and not wants. You know, I should go to uni. I should know what I want to do by now.
在25岁时还会想要的东西。有太多事情是我们永远无法预见或提前计划的。所以你真的需要给自己留出灵活变通的空间。我觉得其次，在如此年轻的时候就把自己框定住，会让我们做出非常情绪化、不切实际的目标，最终只会让我们觉得自己是个失败者，或者走上一条我们其实并不真正向往的道路。你知道的，这会产生很多长期的不满和焦虑，因为我们的大多数人生规划都是基于“应该”而不是“想要”。你知道的，我“应该”上大学。我到这个年纪“应该”知道自己想做什么。
I should own a home by 30. I should be looking to settle down. And I really disagree with that. I think that we need to give ourselves time to explore what we actually desire and want from our lives. And I think that is an incredibly beneficial and empowering part of our 20s. You know, at the end of the day, the five-year plan is a myth for so many reasons. And we're going to discuss all of them from the psychology behind societal conventions of a traditional life, the theoretical concept of the butterfly effect, smart versus hard goals, the just overall generational
我到30岁“应该”拥有一个家。我“应该”开始考虑安定下来了。我非常不同意这种看法。我认为我们需要给自己时间去探索我们内心真正渴望和想要的生活是什么样的。我认为这是我们二十岁时一段极其受益且赋予力量的经历。你知道的，归根结底，五年计划之所以在很多方面都是一个迷思，是有原因的。我们将从社会对传统生活的传统的心理学、蝴蝶效应的理论概念、SMART目标与HARD目标的对比、整个世代
shift towards a greater acceptance of alternative life paths and the psychological explanation for impulsive decisions. We really just have so much to cover today. This episode is ridiculous. There is just so much fascinating research and science and psychology. I'm really, I'm so excited to get into it. So for all of my lovely listeners out there questioning what they want, want from their future, where they're going to be in five years and trying desperately to plan out every single move and counter move and change. This episode is for you. We are going to break down all of the misconceptions about the five-year plan and so much more. So without further ado, let's get into it. All righty, let's start with our basics. For those of us who don't know what a five-year plan is,
对多元生活方式的更大接纳度这一整体转变，以及冲动行为的心理学解释等方方面面进行探讨。今天我们要涵盖的内容实在是太多了。这一期节目简直太不可思议了。里面有太多引人入胜的研究、科学和心理学知识。我真的、我真的非常期待深入探讨。所以，对于所有那些对未来充满疑惑、不知道自己想要什么、不知道五年后自己会在哪里、正拼命试图规划每一个举动、每一步应对措施和每一个改变的可爱听友们。这一期节目就是为你准备的。我们将剖析关于五年计划的所有误区以及更多内容。所以，废话不多说，让我们切入正题吧。好啦，让我们从基础知识开始。对于那些不知道什么是五年计划的人来说，
Essentially, it's this idea of creating a map or an outline of the goals, professional and personal, that we want to meet in the next five years. It's very frequently used in organizational psychology and self-development as kind of a tool for essentially treating our lives like a checklist. You know, become a manager at 22, check, buy a big house, check, get married, check, all of those things. And it really pushes this narrative of a linear, cohesive ladder to success, whereby if we have an idea of where we want to be in five years, we can ultimately work backwards to create strategies and targets for ourselves. Interestingly, and a super weird history fact is that this concept of a five-year plan,
本质上，这就是这样一个概念：为我们希望在未来五年内实现的职业和个人目标画一张地图或列一份大纲。它经常被用在组织心理学和自我发展中，作为一种基本上把我们的生活当作检查清单来对待的工具。你知道的，22岁成为经理，打勾；买一套大房子，打勾；结婚，打勾；所有这些事情。它大力推行的是一种线性、连贯的成功阶梯式的叙事，即如果我们对五年后自己想达到什么位置有个概念，我们最终就可以倒推出策略和目标来达成它。有趣的是，一个超级奇怪的历史事实是，五年计划这个概念，
it actually came from Soviet Russia and communist China. I know that is super strange, but back in the like 1920s and 30s, essentially Stalin decided that he wanted to transform what was then the Soviet Union. So he created this infamous five-year plan of every small thing his country was going to achieve to become an industrial superpower. He had this vision of the next five years for this nation. And that is kind of what inspired the modern individual five-year plan. Literally Soviet Russia, so strange. But nowadays, obviously, it has a completely.
实际上起源于苏联和共产主义中国。我知道这听起来超级奇怪，但在20世纪20和30年代左右，斯大林基本上决定改造当时的苏联。于是他炮制了这个声名狼藉的五年计划，涵盖了他国家为了成为工业超级大国而要实现的每一件小事。他对这个国家未来五年有着这样一个宏伟愿景。而这正是现代个人五年计划的灵感来源。简直就是苏联式的，太奇怪了。但如今，很显然，它有了一个完全
different meaning and this idea of being able to consciously and deliberately map out our lives has really begun to rise in popularity, especially around points of critical change, such as at the end of high school, the end of university and our mid-20s and early 30s, it rests on this belief that we can be forward-focused and create a timeline and steps around that timeline to achieve our goals. And the limits of this plan are really endless, you know, from planning out our finances to our professional goals, our career ambitions, timelines for promotions and huge life changes, like moving cities, having children, anything we strive towards in life, we can put down into this plan or agenda. And I remember when I was in high school, I had to do one of these. Like,
不同的含义，这种能够有意识、刻意地规划我们生活的主张开始越来越受欢迎，尤其是在面临关键转折点的时候，比如高中毕业、大学毕业以及二十多岁到三十岁出头的时候。它基于这样一种信念：我们可以将目光放长远，并围绕这个时间表创建时间线和步骤来达成目标。这种计划的局限性可以说是无止境的，你知道的，从规划我们的财务到职业目标、职业雄心、晋升时间表以及重大的生活改变，比如搬到不同的城市、生孩子，我们在生活中奋斗的任何事情，都可以放进这个计划或议程里。我记得我上高中时，就不得不做过这样一个东西。就像是，
they seemed to be a favorite of school and career counselors. And we had to sit down with this diagram that was printed off from the internet and write down where we would go to university, what our dream job was, what city we would be living in when we were like 23. I think the people who are a big fan of this method, they really highlight the benefit of a plan, specifically one that is discrete, so five years or 10 years, for creating a vision of your life, increasing motivation, allowing us to stay aligned with our ambitions and ultimately leading a very happy, fulfilling life. And I won't deny there has been some research that has shown that having a sense of a plan may actually produce these outcomes, you know, in psychology, visualization and planning activities
它们似乎是学校和职业顾问的最爱。我们不得不坐下来，对照着从网上打印出来的图表，写下我们会去哪所大学上学、我们的梦想工作是什么、当我们大约23岁时会住在哪个城市。我觉得那些非常迷恋这种方法的人，他们确实强调了计划的好处，特别是那种离散的计划（即五年或十年），它能为你的生活建立愿景，增强动力，让我们始终与雄心保持一致，并最终过上非常幸福、充实的生活。而且我不会否认，确实有一些研究表明，拥有计划感实际上可能会产生这些结果，你知道的，在心理学中，可视化和规划活动
are actually an evidence-based tool for increasing motivation and focus. There was also this really unique study conducted by the University of Melbourne. and they examined almost, I think it was like 4,000 people across 15 years, and they found that those who had clear-cut goals, both short and long-term, they were happier than those who didn't. You know, it makes sense, right? Like a plan or some sense of direction does prevent us from living aimlessly. But sometimes I think we can be too stubborn and inflexible if we begin to believe that we need to have everything
实际上是增强动力和专注力的循证工具。墨尔本大学也曾进行过一项非常独特的研讨。他们调查了将近，我想大约是15年里的4000人左右，他们发现那些拥有明确目标（无论是短期还是长期）的人，比没有的人更快乐。你知道的，这讲得通，对吧？一份计划或某种方向感确实能防止我们漫无目的地生活。但有时我觉得，如果我们开始坚信自己必须把一切都
sorted and that we even know exactly what we want from our lives at such a young age in our 20s. I think also the sole premise of this idea is that we can plan for the future, which I think we all know we can't. No matter how hard you try, life is going to throw you some wild curveballs. And I think that's where the myth is contained. You don't need to plan out your whole life to be I think additionally, feeling like you need to stick by some plan or idea of success you had five years ago or even a year ago is such nonsense, especially in our 20s. I think the blessing of this decade is that you get to change and try new things. It's not all about progress and goal setting. But I do think that a lot of the pressure to have some sense of a five year or 10 year plan for
安排妥当，甚至在二十岁这样年轻的年纪就知道自己对生活到底想要什么，那我们就会变得过于固执和不知变通。我也认为，这个想法的核心前提是我们能够为未来做计划，而我认为我们大家都知道自己做不到。无论你多么努力，生活总会给你抛出一些意料之外的曲线球。我想这就是迷思所在。你不需要规划好你整个人生的所有事情来成为——我觉得此外，感觉自己必须坚守五年前甚至一年前曾有过的某种计划或成功观念，简直是一派胡言，尤其是在我们的二十岁。我觉得这个十年的最大福气在于，你可以去改变、去尝试新事物。这并不全关乎进步和设定目标。但我确实认为，对于必须为我们的人生制定五年或十年计划的很多压力，来自于
our lives comes from very traditional views and expectations that have been imposed by previous generations due to a deep perception of the conventional traditional way of doing things. I talk about the concept of a linear blueprint a lot, but I really do believe that a lot of what we desire in life actually comes from external influences rather than our own internal desires. For example, the desire to have a certain job, to be married by a certain age, to be a homeowner, to settle down, to live a structured and organized life, that is a very outdated blueprint that was created back when our worlds were a lot smaller, when travel was a lot more expensive, when job opportunities and career pathways were limited, when we often stayed in
前几代人强加的非常传统的观点和期望，因为他们对做事有着根深蒂固的传统观念。我经常谈到线性蓝图的概念，但我真的相信，我们在生活中渴望的很多东西，其实都来自于外部的影响，而不是我们内心的真实渴望。例如，渴望拥有一份特定的工作、在某个特定年龄结婚、成为房主、安定下来、过一种结构化和有组织的生活，那是一个非常过时的蓝图，它是过去我们的世界还小得多、旅行成本高得多、就业机会和职业道路很有限、我们通常留在
the same place where we were born, when traditional gender roles were a lot of. more powerful and when we didn't have social media and the internet to see what was out there. And I think therefore the things that we were told to plan and expect for, they were limited in many ways and so were our lives. I think society still enforces this idea of a linear plan that doesn't really leave much room for spontaneity and variation. It can be very subtle. you know, think about all the recent headlines, basically like, scorning millennials for getting married later or for not being able to purchase homes because they are lazy or incapable of saving or, you know, for being selfish because we don't want to have children. That is literally a type of soft power that is subtly telling us what we should be doing and what we're doing wrong. and the persistence of this idea, I think it comes from a place of, I don't know, I think it comes
出生地、传统的性别角色要强大得多、而且我们还没有社交媒体和互联网来了解外面的世界时被创造出来的。因此我认为，那些我们被告知去计划和期待的事情，在很多方面都是局限的，我们的人生也是如此。我认为社会仍然在强加这种线性计划的观念，它并没有给随性和变化留下太多空间。这可能非常微妙，你知道的，想想所有最近的新闻头条，基本上都在指责千禧一代结婚较晚，或者因为懒惰或无力攒钱而买不起房，或者因为不想生孩子而“自私”。这简直就是一种软实力，在潜移默化地告诉我们应该做什么以及我们做错了什么。
from a good place, right? Like previous generations don't really understand the new opportunities that we have and they are resting their ideas on a sense of security that is very outdated. But this persistence, this five-year plan idea, it really suggests that there is a single right place where we should all end up, there is a perfect timeline, there is a right level of status in life, the right kind of levels of accomplishment and everything that falls beyond that is is different and unconventional and strange and perhaps even dangerous as a result we're always going to be fixated on these milestones and this imaginary deadline around what needs to be achieved by when but I think this negates like I said the beauty of growth and change we should really
这种观念的持续存在，我认为它出于一种，我不知道，我觉得它出于一个好的动机，对吧？前几代人并不真正理解我们拥有的新机遇，他们把自己的想法建立在一种早已过时的安全感之上。但这种坚持，这种五年计划的想法，确实暗示着：我们所有人最终都应该落在一个唯一正确的地点、存在着完美的时间表、存在着正确的生活地位水平、正确层次的成就，而任何超出这一范畴的东西都是与众不同的、非传统的、奇怪的、甚至可能是危险的。结果就是，我们将永远执着于这些里程碑，以及关于什么必须在什么时候完成的假想期限。但我认为这抹杀了——正如我所说——成长和改变的美丽。我们真的应该
celebrate being able to change our minds and let life surprise us us, you know, embracing that experience rather than fearing it. Let me just also say, loud and clear, what you thought you wanted at 18 is not going to be what you want at 23 or 30. Absolutely, no way. When I was 18, I wanted to be a politician. I wanted to be like prime minister. And I had a five year plan. I even had a 10 year plan. And it involved, you know, getting perfect grades, graduating university by 22 with like a political science, and then I would get an internship and in five years time I would be a political staffer working my way up. That is ridiculous to me now because I have completely different ambitions.
庆祝自己能够改变心意，让生活给我们带来惊喜，去拥抱那种体验，而不是害怕它。让我同样明确而大声地指出，你在18岁时以为自己想要的，绝对不会是你23岁或30岁时想要的东西。绝对不可能。我18岁时，想成为一名政治家。我想当首相。我有一个五年计划。我甚至还有一个十年计划。其中包含着，你知道的，取得完美的成绩，在22岁时大学毕业并获得政治学学位，然后我会去实习，五年内我将成为一名在职场不断晋升的政治幕僚。现在回想起来这太荒谬了，因为我已经有了完全不同的雄心。
And if I had stayed on that path, if I had adhered to my original five year plan, I would have missed out on so much. I would have missed out on this. And I can't really identify when things changed, but there is this idea called the butterfly effect that I think really explains that shift that a lot of us go through so well. So the butterfly effect, it's this theoretical concept, which suggests that a small, seemingly insignificant event or action
如果我当时留在那条路上，如果我坚持我最初的五年计划，我就会错过太多东西。我就会错过这一切。我无法确切指出事情是在什么时候改变的，但有一个叫“蝴蝶效应”的概念，我觉得它非常好地解释了我们许多人所经历的那种转变。所以蝴蝶效应，这是一个理论概念，它表明一个微小的、看似微不足道的事件或行动，
can have far-reaching and unpredictable consequences over time. So the saying is derived from like the metaphor of a butterfly, flapping its wings in one place and setting off a chain of events that eventually kind of leads to a tornado. And it highlights the idea that, Even minor actions or decisions can have profound and unanticipated effects. You know, you are on one path and then you take a university course that changes your entire perspective or you meet someone in passing, you have a chat with a friend, something pops up, some random
随着时间的推移，可能会产生深远且无法预测的后果。所以这个说法源于这样一个隐喻：一只蝴蝶在某个地方扇动翅膀，引发了一系列事件，最终导致了一场龙卷风。它突显了这样一个观点：即使是微小的行动或决定，也能产生深远且意想不到的影响。你知道的，你正走在一条路上，然后你选了一门大学课程，它改变了你整个视角；或者你在擦肩而过时遇到了某人，跟朋友聊了会儿天，有什么事情突然冒出来，某个随机的
opportunity and that one small thing can completely alter your plans. And these things are so tiny and at times insignificant that we cannot plan for them. We cannot make them part of our five-year plan. And then they suddenly change everything. They guide us onto a new path. And you can consider them a sign from the universe or God or your subconscious, whatever you want to call it. All I'm saying is these smallest events can be life-changing.
机会，而那一件小事就能彻底改变你的计划。这些事情是如此微小，有时甚至微不足道，以至于我们无法为它们做计划。我们无法把它们纳入我们的五年计划中。然后它们突然改变了一切。它们引导我们走上一条新路。你可以把它们看作是来自宇宙、上帝或你潜意识的某种迹象，随你喜欢怎么称呼它。我只想说，这些最小的事件都可能是改变命运的。
And ignoring the urge or the inspiration they give you for the sake of some arbitrary goal or plan may actually be the worst choice of your life. You know, I think another part of this is, that regardless of where you'll think you'll end up, sometimes you will just have an impulse to try something different. And psychologically, this can be due to feelings of dissatisfaction and unconscious discontent or just the desire for novelty and excitement. You know, humans, we have this innate need for novelty and stimulation,
为了某个随意的目标或计划而忽视那种冲动或它们带给你的灵感，实际上可能是你人生中做出的最糟糕的选择。你知道的，我认为这其中的另一个部分是，无论你认为自己最终会走到哪里，有时你就是会产生尝试不同事物的冲动。从心理学上讲，这可能是由于不满感和潜意识的不满情绪，或者仅仅是因为对新鲜感和刺激的渴望。你知道的，人类，我们对新鲜感和刺激有着这种与生俱来的需求，
for thinking and doing things that are different and new. And when our lives become routine or monotonous, we may experience almost like this craving for change and a new experience to move to an entirely new country, to quit our jobs, to change career paths. And that could be the best decision you ever made. That could be the start of a whole new and improved life and future, one that is a lot better for you. But you're not going to know that unless you try. and that means breaking out of the convention of feeling like you need to plan for your future and you need a strict timeline for your life because I do believe that when you feel that spark, you do have a duty to chase it and a five-year plan or feeling like you are restricted
想要思考和做一些不同且崭新的事情。当我们的生活变得单调乏味或公式化时，我们可能会经历一种几乎类似于对改变和新体验的渴望，想要搬到一个全新的国家、辞掉工作、改变职业道路。那可能是你做过的最好的决定。那可能是一个全新且经改善的生活与未来的开始，一个对你来说好得多的未来。但除非你尝试，否则你不会知道。这意味着打破那种觉得你需要为未来做计划、你的人生需要严格时间表的陈规旧俗，因为我确实相信，当你感受到那个火花时，你确实有责任去追逐它，而五年计划或那种受到限制的感觉
doesn't really leave room for spontaneity. The other reason and element of why I think the idea of a five-year plan is not only a myth, but kind of limiting is around the psychology of long-term goal setting. Five years is actually quite a long time. Not only can a lot happen that is unexpected, but I think additionally, sometimes we forget how simultaneously long and short that period is. As humans, we are not great at measuring time horizons,
并没有真正为随性留下空间。我认为五年计划不仅是一个迷思、而且具有局限性的另一个原因和要素，与长期目标设定的心理学有关。五年其实是一段相当长的时间。不仅会发生很多意料之外的事，而且我认为除此之外，有时我们会忘记这段时期既长又短的矛盾属性。作为人类，我们在衡量时间跨度方面并不在行，
and that can cause us to make unrealistic and superficial goals. And I think that is especially the case in our 20s. if you are in your early or mid-20s, five years ago, you were still a teenager. And that feels like a lifetime ago for many of us, but also five years before that, you were a literal child. We don't really know what five years feels like as an adult. We don't really have the hindsight, I guess, or the experience to know what we can actually accomplish in that time, to know what could happen. So we tend to go into making a plan for our lives with a lack of information, a lack of hindsight, I guess, but also an emotional bias, which causes us to create
这会导致我们制定出不切实际且流于表面的目标。我认为在我们的二十岁尤其如此。如果你正处于二十岁出头或二十岁中期，五年前，你还只是个青少年。对我们许多人来说，那感觉像是一生那么久远，但同样，在这之前的五年，你还是个字面意义上的小孩子。作为成年人，我们并不真正知道五年是什么感觉。我想，我们没有后见之明，也没有足够的经验来了解我们在那段时间里到底能完成什么，了解可能会发生什么。所以我们在着手制定生活计划时，往往带着信息不足、后见之明不足的局限，我想，同时还带有情绪偏见，这导致我们制定出
very ambitious goals because, you know, the world is full of possibility and we don't really have an understanding of reality yet, but we don't also have an understanding of what we actually want because we haven't had the chance to fail and to try new things and to make mistakes. Let me give an example here that really, I think, puts this into perspective. maybe in five years you imagine yourself owning a home and working for yourself. That is a super admirable vision. That's what I want to do at least. And it's good to have something to work towards.
非常宏大的目标，因为，你知道的，世界充满了无限可能，我们对现实还没有真正的理解，但我们对我们真正想要什么也没有理解，因为我们还没有机会去经历失败、尝试新事物和犯错误。在这里我举个例子，我认为它真正把这一点放到了正确的视角下。也许在五年内，你想象自己拥有一处房产并为自己打工。那是一个超级令人钦佩的愿景。至少这也是我想做的。而且有为之奋斗的目标是件好事。
But at 22, 23, 24, we still have so much time for our lives to change. We don't really have a grasp yet of maybe where we want to settle down. We may not realize just how hard it is to be a homeowner, what that means for our flexibility and our ability to travel, what that means for our finances and our future, all we really think about is the light at the end of the tunnel, the really emotional, inspiring, grand ambition. Often that also means that the goals that we place into our five-year or 10-year plan are not structured in a way that is actually going to guide us. There's this distinction in psychology of smart versus hard goals. So smart is actually an accurate.
但在22、23、24岁时，我们的人生还有大把的时间去改变。我们可能还没真正掌握自己到底想在哪里安定下来。我们可能还没意识到成为一名房主有多么艰难，这对我们的灵活性和旅行能力意味着什么，对我们的财务和未来意味着什么，我们满脑子想的只是隧道尽头的曙光、那种极具情绪感染力、鼓舞人心的宏大抱负。通常这意味着我们放进五年或十年计划中的目标，其结构并不能真正引导我们。心理学中有一个关于智能目标（SMART）与硬性目标（HARD）的区分。所以SMART实际上是一个缩写，
for specific, measurable, achievable, relevant, and time bound. These are the kinds of goals we should have, ones that are realistic, clearly defined, with a clear direction and focus, and also relevant. So relevancy here is important because who can say what goals we have now are going to be relevant for the life we want in five years. You know, everything is kind of up in the air a little bit in our 20s. That's a bit of a sidebar because regardless of that, I really do think smart goals are the way to go, but we often engage in a lot of delusional,
代表具体（Specific）、可测量（Measurable）、可达到（Achievable）、相关（Relevant）和有时限（Time-bound）。这些是我们应该拥有的目标，那些切实可行、定义清晰、有明确方向和焦点、并且相关的目标。所以这里的相关性很重要，因为谁能说我们现在的目标在五年后我们想要的生活中依然相关呢？你知道的，在二十岁时，一切都有点悬而未决。这有点题外话，抛开这些不谈，我真的认为SMART目标才是王道，但我们在二十岁时经常陷入许多妄想、
fantasy, emotional thinking in our 20s, and we can make what we call hard goals instead. So hard stands for heartfelt, animated, required, and difficult. These kinds of goals, they are still important, but they emphasize the kinds of ideas or visions we have that are very emotional and can be quite challenging. Both are important, but when we are smart about what we want, we prevent that delusional thinking, we are realistic, and I guess we don't set ourselves up to be putting ourselves on a timeline that is a lot of pressure or that's going to put us in a place that we don't actually want to be. I think when we absent mindingly concoct a plan for our lives without actually having concrete steps, we overestimate, exist.
幻想、情绪化思维中，结果我们可能会转而制定所谓的硬性目标（HARD）。所以HARD代表衷心（Heartfelt）、充满活力（Animated）、必需（Required）和困难（Difficult）。这类目标虽然仍然重要，但它们强调的是我们所拥有的那些非常情绪化且可能相当具有挑战性的想法或愿景。两者都很重要，但当我们对想要的东西保持精明理智时，我们就能避免那种妄想思维，做到切合实际，我想，我们也不会让自己陷入一个压力山大、或者把我们置于我们其实并不想去的地方的时间表中。我认为，当我们心不在焉地拼凑出一份生活计划，却没有实际的具体步骤时，我们高估了自己
exactly what we will be able to achieve. And these kinds of goals are very difficult to follow, resulting in kind of a sense of failure, but also a sense of pressure in the meantime. When we haven't actually failed, we've just let ourselves be flexible and we have embraced the twists and turns of life. You know, life is not static. It's never going to be the same. But also, I personally believe that our five-year plans, like I said before, have us focused on the shoulds and not the wants in life. You know, I should do things. I should have a long-term partner. I should have found my dream job instead of the wants. You know, I want to have time to explore. I want to travel. I want to try new things before settling. Our wants are normally not as celebrated as our
究竟能取得什么成就。而且这类目标非常难以遵循，结果在过程中不仅产生了一种失败感，还带来了一种压力感。当我们其实并未经历失败，只是让自己保持灵活并拥抱生活的风风雨雨时。你知道的，生活不是静态的。它永远不会一成不变。但同时，我个人认为，正如我之前所说，我们的五年计划让我们只专注于生活中的“应该”，而不是“想要”。你知道的，我“应该”做某些事。我“应该”有一个长期伴侣。我“应该”找到我的梦想工作，而不是关注“想要”。你知道的，我“想要”有时间去探索。我“想要”去旅行。我“想要”在安定下来之前尝试新事物。我们的“想要”通常不像我们的
shoulds. And that's disappointing, especially as this generation becomes, I would say a lot more liberated and open-minded in their ideas of what constitutes a good life. So I really want to talk about that a bit more in just a second. Five-year plans and all structured thinking about the future is something I think in general needs to be avoided because we don't want to, like I said, box ourselves into one idea of happiness and the future that leaves us unresponsive to change and new goals and new ideas. I think in the past, as we described, our society has really reprimanded people who have gone against the fold in so many ways. But that is really changing these days, especially in this younger generation. The example I always think about, I don't know if you guys are on this
“应该”那样受到赞美。这令人失望，尤其是当这一代人变得——我想说——在他们对什么是美好生活的看法上变得更加解放和开明的时候。所以我真的很想在一会儿再多聊聊这个。五年计划以及所有关于未来的结构化思考，我认为总体上是需要避免的，因为正如我所说，我们不想把自己框定在对幸福和未来的单一构想中，导致我们对改变、新目标和新想法毫无应变能力。我认为在过去，正如我们所描述的那样，我们的社会在很多方面确实惩罚了那些特立独行的人。但这在今天真的在改变，尤其是在这个年轻一代中。我总是想到的那个例子——我不知道你们是不是也刷到过这个
algorithm as well, but I'm always saying like these amazing, like, solo female travelers and like everyone is like hyping them up. There seems to be this like praise for people who are doing things that are against the norman there is such a revolt amongst this generation of working you know the same job for the rest of our lives and needing to do things a certain way like I really feel like the people in my life who I really admire the most of people who decide to change their minds like one of my friends is like upping her entire life moving to like an island off of Australia another one of this like moving to the UK she doesn't really have a plan she just like wants to do it.
算法，但我总是看到这些了不起的、独自旅行的女性，每个人都在为她们疯狂打call。似乎社会对那些做着打破常规事情的人充满了赞美，这一代人中也掀起了一场反叛，拒绝像过去那样在一份工作上干一辈子，拒绝凡事必须按某种既定方式去做——我真的觉得我生活中那些我最敬佩的人，都是那些决定改变心意的人。比如我的朋友正准备把整个人生连根拔起，搬到一个澳大利亚离岛；另一个则搬去了英国，她其实并没有什么计划，她只是“想去”。
And that's totally different to what she was doing before, like working in government. It's just nowadays I do think there is a greater acceptance because us Gen Zia's and millennials are really beginning to exhibit a shift in attitudes towards a traditional life and a life plan. I think for a number of reasons we have grown up in a very rapidly changing economic landscape marked by, you know, financial instability, job market fluctuations, the global financial crisis. You know, we've witnessed recessions. We've witnessed student loan debt and limited job opportunities. This exposure has really led us to question the traditional notion that a five-year plan is in some
这跟她以前在政府部门工作时完全不同。只是如今我确实认为社会有了更大的接纳度，因为我们Z世代和千禧一代确实开始展现出对传统生活和人生规划态度的转变。我认为由于种种原因，我们在一个快速变化的经济环境中长大，其标志是经济不稳定、就业市场波动、全球金融危机。你知道的，我们见证了经济衰退。我们见证了学生贷款债务和有限的就业机会。这种经历确实让我们开始质疑那种“五年计划会在某种程度上保护我们或让我们感到更有安全感”的传统观念。我们只是在拒绝那张蓝图。我想我们还渴望探索、建立联系、
ways going to protect us or make us feel more secure. We're just rejecting that blueprint. I think we also have a desire to explore and connect. and find meaningful work and experiences, which I think is a luxury that previous generations, particularly like our grandparents, didn't have. And that is so wonderful. And I want to see more of that, more freedom to actually figure yourself out before being tied down to some future that we felt like we had to decide for ourselves. Often when we were still in high school or like our very, very early 20s. But I'm also not saying, you know, go out and chase everything on a whim. Having some general sense of direction is always a good idea. You know, you should be constantly
寻找有意义的工作和经历，我认为这是一种前几代人（特别是我们的祖父母辈）所不具备的奢侈。这太棒了。我希望看到更多这样的现象，拥有更多的自由去真正搞懂自己，而不是被束缚在某个我们觉得必须为自己决定的未来里。通常那时我们还在上高中，或者才二十岁出头甚至刚出头。但我也不是在说：去吧，随心所欲地去追求一切吧。拥有某种大致的方向感总归是个好主意。你知道的，你应该不断地
revising that and exploring that and reflecting on what's going to make you happy. You know, I did a whole episode on building consistency because I think it's important. And I also think there are some people that just naturally thrive within structure and through planning. You know, the very colloquial term for these people in psychology is type A, people who like routine and to be organized and future focused and set goals for themselves. These people just naturally have a very different temperament. And I'm definitely one of these people or I used to be. I think in those situations and if you are that kind of person and you know that's your
修正、探索并反思什么能让你快乐。你知道的，我做过一整期关于建立稳定性的节目，因为我认为这很重要。而且我也认为确实有些人天生就适合在结构化和规划中蓬勃发展。心理学对这类人的通俗称呼是A型人格，他们喜欢常规、喜欢井井有条、以未来为导向并为自己设定目标。这些人天生就有着非常不同的气质。我绝对是这种人，或者我曾经是。我认为在那种情况下，如果你就是那种人，而且你知道这就是你的
personality, a five-year plan or any kind of blueprint or timeline brings a sense of security, especially to the chaos of our 20s, which I think is why we often have so much anxiety over the future and where it's going. And we kind of resort to feeling like we can plan out. Every single king can change and everything that we want to do. That provides this, I think, it provides a sense of security, but it's kind of a fantasy, right? I think it relieves and releases our anxiety in the moment, but that's like the only benefit, because very few of us will actually stick to that plan. And I think those of us who do might find that it actually is more restrictive than just feeling a little bit anxious or worried sometimes, you know, and there are certain
个性，那么五年计划或任何形式的蓝图与时间表都会带来一种安全感，尤其是在我们二十岁的混乱时期，我认为这也是为什么我们经常对未来及其走向感到如此焦虑的原因。我们最终诉诸于感觉我们可以规划出
jobs that it is applicable for. You know, if you want to be a loyal, or a doctor, well, there are definitely some structured hoops that you need to get through. And you don't want to lose side of what may be a huge goal for you. I think also being able to visualize and map out your progress towards this end goal is highly valuable. But I think the better thing to do and the journey and the path to take that is more healthy and abundant and provides you more room for growth is to leave room for mistakes. stakes. When you think about the future, you might have a vision, but instead of focusing on what material things you'll have, what accomplishments you'll have achieved by then, think about how
每一个细节、一切都可能改变以及我们想做的所有事情。这提供了——我认为，它提供了一种安全感，但它有点像是一种幻想，对吧？它确实在当下缓解和释放了我们的焦虑，但这似乎是唯一的益处，因为我们当中极少有人会真正坚持那个计划。而且我认为那些坚持下来的人可能会发现，它其实比偶尔感到焦虑或担忧更具限制性，你知道的，而且有些工作确实适用这种模式。你知道的，如果你想成为一名律师或医生，好吧，确实有一些必须通过的结构化门槛。你不会想失去对可能成为你巨大目标的视线的。我认为，能够将自己朝着这个终极目标的进展进行可视化和规划也是极有价值的。但我认为更好的做法、更健康、更充裕且能为你提供更多成长空间的旅程和道路是：给错误留出空间。
you feel in that moment. Think about how you're going to feel in five years. Do you want to be someone who is happy and what does happiness look like for you in that moment? Does it look like peace and quiet? Or does it look like extroversion and excitement and socializing and networking? That is a better way to structure your goals rather than feeling like there are a series of hoops and checklists that you need to tick off if you're going to reach a future that you actually desire. You know, leave room for surprises. Reinforce that it's okay to change your mind. It's okay to do something different. Even if it's not what everyone else is doing, even if it's not what your parents told you you should do or society told you should do or you never thought you'd be doing.
当你思考未来时，你可能会有一个愿景，但与其关注你将拥有什么物质财富、到那时你将取得什么成就，不如想想你在那一刻的感觉。想想你在五年后的感觉会怎样。你想成为一个快乐的人吗？对你来说，那一刻的幸福是什么样子的？它看起来像是一片平和与宁静吗？还是看起来像是外向、兴奋、社交和建立人脉？这是一种更好的设定目标的方式，而不是觉得自己有一连串的门槛和检查清单需要勾选，以此来抵达一个你其实并不真正渴望的未来。你知道的，给惊喜留出空间。强化这样一个观念：改变心意是可以的。做点不同的事情是可以的。哪怕这跟其他人做的不一样，哪怕这不是你父母或社会告诉你“应该”做的事，哪怕你从没想过自己会去这样做。
sometimes that's where the greatest growth kind of happens. And a five-year plan, no five-year plan, ten-year plan, no plan at all. You know, my opinion, I do still think that you are going to be okay. We as a species are highly adaptive. We know how to survive. And at any point, you can get back onto a very concrete path, if that's the kind of path that you want, you know. I guess the message at the end of the day, the reason a five-year plan is a myth is because it doesn't allow for change.
有时候，最伟大的成长正是在那里发生的。五年计划也好，没有五年计划、十年计划、甚至完全没有计划也罢。你知道的，我的看法是，你依然会好好的。我们作为一个物种，具有极强的适应能力。我们知道如何生存。而且在任何时候，如果你愿意，你都可以重新回到一条非常具体的道路上来，如果那是你想要的道路的话。我想，归根结底，五年计划之所以是一个迷思，是因为它不容许改变。
And change is the biggest and most important element and characteristic of our 20s. So I really hope that if you're someone who is worrying about your future, trying very hard to contain or control every single circumstance, this episode has kind of helped you release some of that anxiety and be more comfortable with that uncertainty. You don't have to have everything sorted out. I definitely don't. I don't really know anyone in my life who does. So I just hope you enjoyed this episode. I hope you learnt something as always. I always say this, but if there is someone in your life who needs to hear this, you should send it to them, send them a link, let them know that this is out there and maybe they should listen to it, obviously, only if you feel called to do so, but you could really help someone out. That's what I, that's what I always like to think.
而改变正是我们二十岁时最大、最重要的元素和特征。所以我真心希望，如果你是一个正为未来担忧、极力想要控制每一个环境的人，这一期节目能帮你释放一些焦虑，让你对这种不确定性感到更加坦然。你不需要把一切都安排得井井有条。我绝对没有。我真的不认识我生命中有谁做到了。所以我只是希望你喜欢这一期节目。希望你和往常一样学到了一些东西。我总是这么说，但如果你的生活中有人需要听听这个，你应该把节目发给他们，把链接发给他们，让他们知道有这样一个节目，或许他们应该听听——当然，只有在你觉得有此召唤时才这么做，但你真的可能会帮到某人。这就是我，我总是这么想的。
And if you did enjoy today's episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. It takes a couple of seconds. It really helps the show grow. It helps support me. And it would just be really nice. I read all of your reviews. They make me super, super happy. So thank you for those who have shown their support.
如果你确实喜欢今天的节目，请随时在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你现在正在收听的任何地方留下五星好评。这只需要几秒钟。它真的对节目的成长大有帮助。它有助于支持我。而且这感觉会非常棒。我阅读了你们所有的好评。它们让我超级、超级开心。所以谢谢那些给予支持的听友们。
If you have an episode suggestion, please follow me at that psychology podcast. I get so many amazing ideas. I love to hear what some of our experiences are that maybe I'm not having, but that I can recognize in my friends or amongst other people in this generation. I often take your suggestions and turn them into full episodes. So please feel free to follow me over there, see what we're up to. And as always, we will be back later this week with another episode. Hey, what's good, y'all?
如果你有节目建议，请在那个心理学播客（that psychology podcast）上关注我。我收到了太多精彩的点子了。我喜欢听听我们有哪些经历，也许我没有经历过，但我能在我的朋友们或这一代人当中产生共鸣。我经常采纳你们的建议并将其转化为完整的节目。所以请随时去那里关注我，看看我们在做些什么。一如既往，我们将在本周晚些时候带着另一期节目回归。嘿，大家好，
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite. therapist and hosts care games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
您正在收听由您喜爱的治疗师和主持人Care Games带来的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间聚焦于黑人男性的经历，进行在其他地方极不安全但却坦诚的对话，而您是在与一位知分寸的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套或多重盔甲？这向世界发出信号：你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有能力就必须这样做。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2%。这是在旁边有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、体能和抗逆力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。名字就是TWA%，可在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。
When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
当一群女性发现她们都与同一个惯犯骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女性朋友。收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。
On the iHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at a podcast. That was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。在播客《Look Back at It》中。这对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。1984年对我意义重大。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会选择一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着弄清楚我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的伙伴以及最喜爱的作家们一起。
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. I mean, it was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代那样。1984年真是疯狂的一年。我是说，那真是疯狂的一年。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。这是一个iHeart播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。